in scrabble circles it's a move which
has triggered a war of words
the decision by the games makers to ban
400 of them
deemed to be racial slurs the result
resignations from the official scrabble
players association
arguments and general outrage if i went
through
uh every dictionary and book in the
world and for example remove the name
hitler
would that stop us ever talking about it
no but what it would do is potentially
stop us from learning
from the past and i think removing the
words could do that
and if racist words are being ditched
it's being questioned why
other derogatory terms like chav or
wrinkly
remain mattel which owns the rights to
scrabble outside
north america said it had made its
decision following the black lives
matter protest last summer
and that in order to attract a new
generation of players
it was time to modernize the game
it's refused to publish the list but
it's said to include terms that insult
black pakistani and irish people
and also words that mean non-jewish i do
think there is an over
emphasis on on language at the moment
and it distracts us
from the real
like deeply entrenched inequalities
that have such a damaging effect
on our society scrabble recently beamed
words onto buildings in london to
reflect people's thoughts about the
easing of lockdown
but as restrictions are lifted there's
anger among sections of scrabble's
competitive elite
that the move by the makers of their
beloved game has in fact taken away the
freedom to play as they wish
emma birchley sky news south london